une chanson bonjour arbon choix de jean
max rivière
encore une histoire d'amour celle là
c'était entre un petit poisson et un
petit resto un petit poisson petit
oiseau c'est madame ans quand et comment
s'y prendre quand on est donc un petit
poisson un petit oiseau sma d'amour
tendre mais comment s'y prendre quand on
est là où
quand on est là où perdu au creux des
nuages on regarde en bas on voir son âme
au final
et l'on voudrait bien changé au cours
des voyages sevran h dans le salon
bourgeois le scellant bennour un petit
poisson petit oiseau celui d'un peu de
temps mais dans mon secret quand on est
là un pic bois sont un petit oiseau
s'aimer d'amour temps mais commençons
par an quand on est dans l'eau dans
l'élan loum
he has
m
un message et
l'échangé d'un voyage des plumes en
détails qu elle en chandail et dessins
dans son réseau et d'amour tendre mais
comment s'y prennent quand on est dans
l'eau un petit poisson un petit oiseau
c'est madame landry
mais comment s'y prendre